his new show medical police is available
for streaming this Friday on a service
called Netflix which I've heard of good
to see you rob huebel how are you sir
thanks for having me rich it's lovely to
be here
and thank you for being aware of Netflix
yes I am you know I'm very aware of it
you know it's out there right now I hear
it's a thing yeah out there on Netflix
right now so people can stream it right
now that's right right now yeah I don't
compete with this where they should not
stream it right now right should watch
this let's let's have a great
conversation some agree that we're done
they're like let's head to Netflix okay
very good
well unless we've already accomplished
that I think so I think we already have
yeah we had a pretty good chat just now
when I just saw you in the greenroom you
were kind enough to say look I'm feeling
a little under the weather yeah he gave
me he gave me the old Howie Mandel elbow
yeah gave me that whole elbow yeah men
shake hands when they're sick exactly
chose and you just returned from the
green city of New Orleans yeah because
you went to the national champion of
game to watch your alma mater Clemson
have added with LSU yeah it didn't go as
planned
it didn't GE aux as planned yes nicely
John no it was listen I blame myself man
come on now I am because I wasn't there
for them rich I feel like I didn't bring
it you know I wasn't on point either
yeah no I mean it was I can't take
anything away from LSU like it was
they're a great team and but if you
could attempt to take away something yes
have a great time in Cincinnati jobber
Oh enjoy that enjoy know I'm sure
Cincinnati's lovely but yeah there there
there there's such a strong team and
he's an amazing player and I think I
heard a bow say this in the press
conference afterward is that he was just
putting the ball in the one spot that
hazing could be put to be caught you
know because there's good coverage most
of the time but he would just put it
like in the perfect spot always
and then Clemson just couldn't get the
spark that they needed you know like I
felt like they were they started off
great and then they kind of just
couldn't get that break
and then a little bit of inaccuracy on
Trevor and Trevor I love you I don't
take offensive yet can you imagine never
lose pretty much his first time since
high school that's correct
oh my gosh yeah that actually happened I
would be just emotionally I would just
be what do you do like do you are you
allowed to cry no do you even know how
to cry you know you know what I wish I
knew because I I suffered many
indignities in high school yeah so we
suffered one yeah what I mean I know it
I got the Heisman on prom night yeah in
high school so yeah yeah I put that
right there on the mantel robbed nice oh
yeah I got into a car accident with my
date on homecoming night and not a bad
one we still made it to the dance but
yeah high school was a disaster which is
why I'm in comedy exactly that well yeah
that's it helps pave the road what was
it like in the stadium though was it
like the 80/20 split that Dabo said it
would be between it was LSU and Clemson
fans no more Clemson people showed up
but because it was pretty it was crazy
if we were it was their home field it
was I would say like 25 75 them okay and
and they were loud and they were drunk
you can get karey where's the camera
that's on me right here right there you
got it here's a warning you can get
drunk in New Orleans good job can get
very drunk and and the game was it like
seven o'clock their time a lot of Swing
oil so they were ready to go and and I
was in the middle of all of these LSU
fans and I was just yelling my head off
the whole time and people kept like
taunting me you know which I was not
down for and all like I think they meant
it in a good natured way but I was like
not having it people be like Pat me on
the back when they would score and I was
like like physically touch touching me
which I was not prepared for or cool
with and a lot of people kept touching
me and then at one point someone from
the rafters threw a beer and it hit the
people in front of me but I thought it
was for me and oh I was furious that's
how things
start that's how things can go but rob
huebel here on the Rich Eisen show what
were you like though up 17-7 I I was
growing yes I was grabbing people and
aggressively and touching them and yeah
I was I was getting pretty obnoxious and
then when it swung back around I was so
it's hard as a fan to to swallow that
and to eat that and and I just had to
and then I I thought like I kept
thinking like I know my team like we're
coming back like we've been we've done
this before and it just didn't happen
it was 28 25 you scored the first point
second half went for two points on that
when they could have just kicked the one
the the extra point and they went for
two and I was like all right like I
guess it's just like here we go well I
think he was beginning to pick up what
we were all picking up what Joe Burrell
was putting down yeah yeah if you if you
have an opportunity to go for one or two
yeah get the more yeah for more because
of the way he was throwing in it is
unbelievable if it needed to be dropped
in a bucket he did it if he needed to
throw the dart he did it if you need to
throw it as a high point he did if he
had to throw it at the pylon
he did it it really it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable in that dude here's
what's crazy the stadium cheers for him
specifically they don't say go Tigers
anymore they go go Joe go like I don't
know what they're gonna do next year
like like I'm sure they'll be fine but
maybe they just have to recruit another
quarterback named Jim maybe someone else
want to play there's another quarterback
you gotta be named Joe because we can't
think everybody they're used to it so
yeah as a Michigan Wolverine fan yes
it's difficult to look and feel sorry
for you man 21 first year that's not why
I'm here rich I don't pretend that
people should feel bad for me I mean we
have a great team gonna have a great
team for a long time and also you know
it all swings around you know like it's
a quick life
the sir you've seen the Lion King how
this ends yeah dude Michigan's gonna get
home with the death of the Father so
you're saying that's every Disney
parents I have a three-year-old the
parents don't need to die in every
Disney movie by the way dude you're just
going through it as a first-time parent
right with a three-year-old yeah my kids
as I explained him off air eleven eight
and six so I'm seeing all the Disney
movies again for the second third and
fourth time right I'm watching Beauty
and the Beast with my kids and I turn to
my wife and I'm like are we teaching our
son that if he finds a young lady he
likes all he needs to do if she's not
really into the idea is take her put her
in the library in the basement and lock
her up with the books that's exactly
what she comes around that's exactly
really what we're teaching your kids
because that's the story arc yeah my
daughter's really into frozen just the
first one so far and and I'm sure the
second one's great calm down Disney and
but you know the parents die in the
first like minute of frozen yeah there's
down with the ship and my daughter's
like kind of confused but she's like so
my daughter hates ships she's like she
doesn't I told her was one in New
Orleans she's like don't go on a ship
daddy don't go on a ship whatever you
did I didn't I flew I can afford it do
you know what yeah but what actually
what you told her is you just you you
froze with your hands she's gonna freeze
the entire land you skated your way to
New Orleans I did I skated all the way
there just like Princess Elsa attaboy
Rob Huebel here on the rich guys to show
you're tight with Riggle right yeah we
came up together in New York yeah we're
at just in comedy or yeah in the comedy
world yeah on the daily show - no well I
worked behind I was a producer at The
Daily Show shout out to the producers
here attaboy and and and but we
performed a lot of improv together and
sketch together we had a two-man sketch
group together and we still do a lot of
stuff together he does you know the NFL
stuff for Fox and so I'd do some of his
bits with him and he's the best man he
is he's the best he's he's fired up
about his Chiefs right dude
he was I was blowing up his phone
because he was he kept posting on
Instagram like during the game and
everyone was like what's going on like
then he was just getting buried and then
they did it and he was like you know
literally his phone was on fire like he
couldn't even respond his Instagram post
was him taking a shot of himself looking
livid saying okay and then stop texting
me I know my team yeah but what a
comeback
I know lievable dude are you I mean the
Super Bowl come on come on
do you have a team or your Redskins my
wife is a big Seahawks fan so therefore
I am a Seahawks fan so I'm kind of
bummed but uh but look it's you know
it's gonna be awesome obviously it's
gonna be Chiefs 49ers no offense to
whoever doesn't think that but it is you
don't think you don't think the Packers
have a shot or Derek Derek Henry is
making grown men think about their
mortality every single time he touches
the ball definitely he's an Alabama guy
right yes you sir dude stuff they're all
tough yeah they're all tough man that's
the takeaway 49ers and Chiefs which I
think a lot of people are thinking too
all of them let's talk about medical
police sir you were in this it's a
parody of international spy thrillers
and Corddry another Augustus yeah this
is what recreated it yeah core jury this
is a spin-off of we used to do show
called Children's Hospital and it's
basically the same show it's a spin-off
of that with a new name and less core
jury we had you know we figured out we
did some testing some focus groups like
less core jury more Hubel I'm so yeah
this so this is mostly me and Erin Hayes
and trying to contain this virus
outbreak that's about to kill the whole
world but it's the same crazy tone as
Children's Hospital which is stolen from
like sucker brothers and like airplane
and Naked Gun and so it's just saying
absurd stuff with a totally straight
face so the best compliment I get on
Twitter right now and everyone keeps
saying this is
this is the dumbest show that I can't
stop watching yes you're a smart pretty
so it's like it's dumb comedy for smart
people I like that yeah did you ever see
police squad dude yeah which is yeah
it's that's what airplane from that yeah
it's all that tone like just Leslie
Nielsen you know is that sort of I mean
he's a you know just a legend like that
sort of ability to just say super dumb
stuff but very seriously well anytime an
umpire showboats
hmm in Major League Baseball I will
tweet out a Jif of enrico pallazzo
breakdancing and all of that stuff yeah
yeah that's the bet that was the best
move rock Chris do we ever get when we
talk about sports movies people saying
that Naked Gun is a sports movie because
of the last 20 minutes of that film we
get that every I would argue that it is
it's also one of the best OJ Simpson
movies that's true too right it's
Nordberg got ejected off of the third
deck of Dodger Stadium to go back and
watch Oh Jay Simpson do comedy like
that's crazy
do they object one of our I think our
directors got my ears saying that he's
seen he's seen it on MLB Network they've
put yeah they put police squad on a
Nikki gun on that amazing amazing well
congrats on on this show again and it's
only only watch it if you're dumb smart
if you're smart but you're kind of dumb
come on now yeah the humor from those
movie is smart and it's um obviously
what you've done is spot-on
thanks for very very funny check it out
right now on Netflix now they can go
right we know right now in the
commercial break we're just for the
television or it's about two short clip
then they can go up your sponsors watch
the commercial thank you sir then go
much appreciate it at Rob Huebel bomb
both Twitter and Instagram medical
police check it out on Netflix right now
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show